senior leadership doesn't get it what do
I do how do I influence them the answer
is you don't you cannot influence other
people what we can do is take
responsibility for the people to the
left of us and the people to the right
of us regardless of where we are in the
corporate hierarchy we can be the lowest
level we still work with or for someone
and we can come to work every day and
work tirelessly to see that those people
rise to see that those people feel seen
and heard and understood that's called
leadership and if we have an infinite
perspective then these teams are going
to be really high functioning and high
performing and one of them one of the
people in those teams may be promoted
out and join another team and they'll
take everything they've learned and
bring it to their new team and then
they'll move on to another team and
before you know it the tales Wag the Dog
before you know it the whole
organization has changed so as long as
we are willing to take an infinite
minded perspective we can affect
profound and positive change in an
organization especially when senior
leadership doesn't get it because our
work will Outlast them